I know it is who it is that wrote this question so I'm going to answer it personally and this
is how you guys can ask questions you could ask questions and if it is really a personal
question that I will look up that person's play it in their protocol and everything so
we'll be reading so we'll have to understand it. You have a lot of my recent test information,
Dutch tests, they're moderately done in December, blood work, much of which I don't understand
as it applies to my condition. I just need your opinion on whether I need to make changes or
continue with what I have been doing so this is the real question right here. I just need to know
so the answer to that question is you recorded I looked at all those all that data and I think you
should just stay on what you are doing don't make any changes based upon that information that you're
setting. Second question is I was also wondered about doing a breast ultrasound coming up in February
haven't done one for seven months it's the last one yeah I think that would be a good idea this
person was doing breast ultrasound I think every three months and we pushed them out every six months
or so I think it would be a good idea yeah I think that would be a good play and get that ultrasound done.